uh what about Alexander from Ohio
Alexander from Ohio what's going on with
you
David sir can you hear me I can hear you
fine
uh I was wondering with the millennial
and younger um population of America
leaning left
um do you think that we will in a couple
decades or so be kind of done with these
insane issues that we've been having to
deal with for the last couple years
what do you mean
well just kind of like
um the fact that everything is
like abortion gun laws these kinds of
all of these issues that
are the most important things in
politics today for us do you think with
the culture kind of leaning left in the
future
a lot of these issues will become just
more like we'll come to a conclusion
about them and then they'll become
non-issues I see what you're saying so
here's the thing
I do believe that many of the cultural
issues from today are not going to
remain cultural issues indefinitely
however
the right which depends on fear and
scapegoating to try to win is going to
move on to something else and then the
question is who then is further
victimized and
um that is a scary sort of proposition
so yeah I don't think the focus will be
what it currently is indefinitely but
then it's like who who will they go
after next and I don't I don't know
they're going to find someone to go
after and to base their culture War
around
so this does all just go on essentially
forever then I don't know about forever
and I don't know about it goes on goes
on like this but I think the point I'm
making is for the foreseeable future if
it's not trans people who are the target
it's going to be someone it's going to
be and and so we just have to be ready
for that
that makes a lot of sense David I was
also wondering what you think of Ohio if
you've ever been here yeah I've been to
uh let's see I've been to Cleveland and
at Cleveland I wasn't huge on it's it
was very pyongyang-like a lot of
concrete brutalist architecture where I
was but I might have only been in one
neighborhood and then I've been to
Columbus which was kind of cool Columbus
had a good this was a long time ago but
it had done a pretty good food scene and
uh yeah I don't have any particularly
um hot takes on uh on Ohio
well that's good because a lot of people
uh often uh you know make jokes about
Ohio but I'm fine with Ohio existing
let's put it that way
well I appreciate you follow David all
right thank you for answering questions
I really appreciate what you do thank
you Alexander from Ohio great to hear
from you